hi there today we're going to look at
Lin former self attention with linear
complexity bi-xenon Huang Belinda Lee
modeun Copsey Han Fung and Hama of
Facebook AI so on a high level
this paper observes that often the way
we build transformers the self attention
matrix is low rank and can be
approximated by first projecting the
signal to a lower dimensional space and
then performing these inner products
that are responsible for attention in
there and thereby you save a lot of the
complexity of multiplying full sequence
length full sequence length by full
sequence length matrices but instead do
these operations in the lower
dimensional space and they achieve a
linear scaling of the transformer
attention and we'll figure out how that
is as always if you like content like
this consider subscribing sharing liking
and commenting if you feel like it
ok let's dive in they say large
transformer models have shown
extraordinary success in achieving
state-of-the-art results in many natural
language processing applications okay so
these if you don't know what a
transformer model is you can watch my
video on the paper attention is all you
need that was sort of the beginning of
these transformers and it introduces the
attention mechanism that we're going to
look at today if you don't know what an
attention mechanism is you're not going
to have a fun time in this paper they
say however training and deploying these
models can be prohibitively costly for
long sequences as the standard self
attention mechanism of the transformer
uses N squared time and space with
respect to the sequence length now why
is that so really shortly to recap recap
this the attention mechanism the these
attention these transformers they
transform four basics let's say they
transform one sequence into an
so here we have five tokens and the next
layer will output five tokens case four
five tokens in five tokens out and the
question is how do you route information
between these five tokens from the first
layer to produce the next layer in a
feed-forward Network you would simply
connect everything to everything and
sort of learn the weights of these of
these connections that's not what we do
here in a convolutional network you
would simply connect each node to its
immediate neighbors like this but this
is also not what we do here what we do
here is we route the information
according to the information itself so
according to the incoming information
right here we route the information that
goes out and we do that by expressing
kirik queries and keys so these incoming
information is transformed first of all
into what are called keys now keys are
simply vectors so each node is going to
expose a vector right here and each node
in the higher layer now these are
produced by the same from the same
information down here but I'm going to
draw it conceptually on the higher layer
so each node here is going to expose a
query which is sort of like calling the
query is calling for what kind of
information do you want from the lower
layer and the key is sort of exposing
what type of information this node
contains right now now the information
is simply routed by looking at the inner
products of these of the keys and the
queries so this information right here
would probably be routed to this node
right here whereas this one would
probably be routed here this one would
be routed here in fact this is a soft
assignment so it's not like a hard
routing it's a soft routing everything
is routed to everything with different
weights but the majority goes to the
place where the inner product is high
and this one is again routed here so you
can see this is the attention mechanism
in order to do this we need to compute
the inner product
of every single one of these queries
with every single one of these keys okay
and this if our sequence length here is
of length n is going to require n
squared operations okay now here is
another parameter we need to pay
attention these vectors here they have a
certain dimension and a certain
dimension we're going to call D the
inner the embedding dimension of the
vectors now in modern transformers you
can think of n as something like maybe
512 tokens go into a transformer like
this and the hidden dimension here also
is in the same order of magnitude so you
can also imagine this to be something
like 512 now if you think of these
matrices if you multiply the keys by the
queries everyone oh let's do it like
this then you have the keys are n by D
and the queries are d by n okay now
since N and D in this case are the same
dimension this matrix is of rank but of
rank 512 doesn't have to be but it's a
pretty good bet that it's of rank 512
maybe it's approximately lower rank but
you know now this isn't actually the
modern way of transformers as such
because usually what we have is
multi-head attention which means that
we're going to split this inner
dimension right here we're going to
split these vectors into many many lower
dimensional vectors and then have a
tension mechanism on these lower
dimensional vectors and that's so such
that you don't only have one attention
mechanism you have multiple attention
mechanism so you can route different
kinds of information with these multiple
attention heads now sometimes you would
split this you could split this in a
modern transformer up to like 16
different heads but here we're going to
let's say we're going to split this into
four sub vectors each of 128 damaged
okay so we're going to split this up and
now if this in this product here is only
computed on these lower dimensional
vectors so all of a sudden you no longer
have n by D but you have like n by D
over four and now this is 512 still but
this now is 128 so the rank of this
matrix is going to be 128 mind it's
still the thing that comes out is still
a 512 by 512 matrix but it is of rank
128 and that means even though this
matrix contains vectors that are of size
512 they could be they could be
represented accurately by a matrix
that's just 128 dimensions okay so these
these 512 dimensions actually only
contain information that is 128
dimensional in nature
it's just distributed over 512
dimensions but most of these are
redundant so in fact in these modern
transformers these thing here this
matrix here is low rank and therefore
that's what this paper sort of exploits
we could we could approximate this by
128 dimensions okay this is our starting
point they go on and they say in this
paper we demonstrate that the self
attention mechanism can be approximated
by a low rank matrix we further exploit
this finding to propose a new self
attention mechanism which reduces the
overall self attention complexity from N
squared to N in both time and space the
resulting linear transformer the Lin
former performs on par with standard
transformer models while being much more
memory and time efficient all right so
let's dive into their thing this is how
they formulate the attention mechanism
so right here the attention has
queries and keys as you can see here now
these W matrices you can largely ignore
the W simply Maps
the queries to so this is these are
simply D by D matrices there are a
linear transformation of the queries you
can sort of overlook them for the
arguments in this paper
so these are the keys and the queries we
talked about the values here this is the
actual information that's being routed
so what we want to do is we want to
compute this product between queries and
keys right here and scale it
appropriately but ultimately this is
this product then run this through a
softmax operation that means we we
normalize it such that it sums to 1 the
distribution sums to 1 and then we want
to route this information according to
that distribution ok so that's how they
formulate an attention mechanism now
notice something this thing in here is
what they call the matrix a and this is
what I've demonstrated to be low rank
now the actual thing that you would need
to be low rank for there paper to hold
is the matrix P which is different
because this is after the softmax right
so if the matrix P is low rank then you
have a legitimate claim of approximating
this routing via a low rank matrix
however if P is not low rank you you
don't ok all right now the first thing
they're going to show is that this is in
fact a low rank so self attention is low
rank and for that they make an empirical
investigation into Roberta
so Roberta is a a model that's based on
Burt and I have made videos of both Burt
and Roberto I believe if sorry if you
want to go look those up but it is one
of these transformer models and they
take two data sets
Wiki 103 and IMDB and they run them
through this model and they look at this
P matrix
they look at how this this information
routing matrix is built and then they
calculate the eigenvalues of that so you
calculate the eigenvalues and by looking
at the eigenvalues you can look at the
rank of a matrix
broadly speaking so if you list the
eigenvalues in order of their size then
a matrix that is sort of high
dimensional has a higher rank would have
sort of a slope like this and that means
as you go as you go to the next and next
next I can validate they drop like if
you order a set of uniformly distributed
numbers if you order them then it would
look like this right so there is no
particular dimension that's that's
better than any or has much more
information than any other however if
the matrix is approximately low rank it
would look something like this and that
would mean that most of the information
is concentrated in very few dimensions
and those are the ones with very high I
ghen values and most of the dimensions
have no information the thing you see
here is simply the cumulative sum of
these things so if you calculate the
cumulative sum of this you'll get that
over here so if this is very high rank
you would expect a curve that goes like
this sort of slanted but not very if
this is very low rank it would expect a
curve that goes very much into the
corner right here and they show that the
general shape here is such that there is
this kind of a kink to it as you can see
here now also notice that the axis here
starts at zero point four so actually
this comes from down here somewhere
and goes up and then goes like this so
they have a I feel they have a
legitimate claim here that these
matrices are approximately low rank and
here they look at I don't actually know
at which layer this is or if this is at
in all of the layers overall or some
like this but they look at how this
develops inside the layers so they look
at the obviously 128th eigenvalue and
they do this discover that as they go
deeper and deeper into the network this
cumulative eigenvalue is higher and
higher that means that network puts more
and more information into fewer and
fewer dimension in this routing as you
go up the layers so it gets more and
more skewed as you go up the layers it
gets more and more into this corner
right here so their claim appears to be
more and more true now I have sort of
thought about this a little and I've
tried it out a bit myself and I invite
you to just follow me here shortly so
right here I have a matrix that is just
a random Gaussian matrix of size 512 by
512 if we look at the eigen spectrum of
that so I have this function as you
idiot simply gives me the eigen spectrum
of that then you can see that it sort of
falls off uniformly and that will result
in a in this cumulative sum of a pretty
much flat curve or slowly ascending
curve like this okay now if we actually
have a low rank matrix this would look
different this would have this sort of
typical kink in it and we can
demonstrate that by making a lower
dimensional matrix so let's just take
let's just go 512 by 128 of this lower
dimensional and and let's look at the M
T now this only goes to 128 because we
only get back 128 singular values so
let's make a lower dimensional matrix
that's actually 512 by 512 so if we do
this this is sort of what they're doing
in the in this this will construct a 512
by 512 matrix but that
is only of rank 128 right and you can
see that at the 128th a singular or
eigenvalue this snaps right at the at
the 1 so it's sort of like what they
what they have okay so we've seen the
difference between a let's say higher
rank matrix and the low rank matrix in
this cumulative sum plot now I'm going
to go back to the original matrix right
here of course they're the matrices they
look at these routing matrices they're
not Gaussian they're not sort of
distributed with mean zero and the nice
variance they are the result of a
softmax operation and in particular that
means they're all positive and that
means that their mean is not zero so if
you look at a data set and its mean it's
not zero and you calculate like the the
eigen values or in this case the
principal component you will find that
the first one will be very strong
because that must account for the fact
that the mean is not at the center the
first few will be like this so it is
sort of maybe we can replicate this
right here so let's can say we'll put em
through let's first go with the absolute
value of M okay not much of a change but
you already see that this axis doesn't
start at zero so let's go let's actually
how do we do this
excellent right x lim zero none so haha
okay so the first one you simply have to
imagine or I can do even something
something more we can just put a zero in
front here and that should do the trick
no yes oh that's X I meant why calm and
um never mind this will work as well so
you already get this sort of of kink and
let's put it into the softmax so we put
a soft max and that gives you also this
kink now you might think that wait this
is that this kink looks a lot smaller
than the other kink so but if we simply
modify let's modify the standard
deviation of this random matrix and you
can see that this spectrum immediately
changes right because of the interaction
now between the softmax and the standard
deviation if I only were to change the
standard deviation on the normal M
matrix and we can actually try this
right here that wouldn't do much that
would still look pretty much the same
it's just differently scaled but in the
interaction with the softmax now this
changes the spectrum dramatically and
here as you know these these
transformers have always sort of like
layer normalization and so on so
probably the standard deviation if we if
if these are sort of Gauss in the
standard deviation before the softmax
would be a lot smaller so let's go
something like this
so smaller than one and can we run this
please and you can see that this kink
immediately appears now it's not it's
it's it's not the same thing as this
other as this here because this is a lot
smoother as you can see right here but
still I feel that this might not
actually be a result of the you know the
fact that this is an attention mechanism
but it simply might be the result of
that you apply a soft max now still that
doesn't change the fact that it is
approximately a low rank matrix so
everything they say holds but yeah maybe
maybe one should also look into why
exactly that
happens but in fact it is low-rank okay
it is approximately the rank they've
demonstrated this and now they go to
their first first theory below
we provide a theoretical answer a
theoretical analysis of the above
spectrum results okay so the theoretical
analysis theorem one is self attention
is low rank and we're going to go
through this just glance at it for now
they say for any of these query key
values and these matrices which of
course you can ignore for now
for any column vector W of matrix V W
and W here that's the information that
needs to be routed there exists a low
rank matrix P tilde so this P tilde here
is going to be there low-rank
approximation of the P matrix you can
see it's still N by M but it's going to
be low ranking in fact it's going to be
of the order of the logarithm of the
rank of the full matrix or well the full
matrix of the rank that the full matrix
could have as we have already seen the
full matrix doesn't have full rank but
yeah okay so if you use and this is the
type of guarantee you get so what do we
see here it basically means that this
distance here is smaller than this and
this here this is just the norm of one
of these vectors projected times this
error coefficient Epsilon so all it says
is that the distance on the left is
smaller than something and that occurs
with high probability okay so the entire
guarantee here the entire formula just
basically means that this thing is small
this norm is small what's this norm this
norm is the distance between these two
things
now what are these two things this is
the information that we want to route
and this is the routing matrix and that
simply means that if I route my
information
using the P tilde this approximation
then I won't be too far away as if I had
routed my information using the original
P matrix okay that's that's it that's
what the theorem says the theorem says
if I route my information using this
approximation then I am not too far away
as it had arrived at my information
using the original routing matrix they
don't say how they're going to construct
they simply say there exists a low rank
matrix like this and the proof of this
and it's sort of worth looking at the
proof of it it uses the johnson lyndon
strauss lemma this thing here or the JL
for short and they're going to get this
out of the jail now the Johnson Lyndon
Strauss lemma in a classic sense says
something like this if I have data in a
high dimensional space here in a three
dimensional space okay I've data
distributed and I use a certain kind of
projection matrix and there are a number
so that the JL gives conditions on what
these projections can be but for example
a randomly sampled matrix with zero mean
Gaussian entries and one over K standard
deviation where K is the dimension you
project into can do the trick so if I
project my data in a certain way into a
lower dimension here dimension two then
the projected data is related to the
original data by the fact that the
distances between the points in the
original space will not be distorted too
much so the distances between these
points are approximately preserved
through this projection okay
so that's that's the that's the Johnson
Lyndon Strauss lemma now you'll notice
here there is no reference to the fact
that this data is or isn't low rank
it's simply high dimensional data
to lower dimension and the distances are
approximately preserved and this theory
here and I've looked at it for a while
now
they simply define okay they define this
P matrix as this attention mechanism and
here you can see the a matrix we've
discussed before which is actually low
rank but we don't know yet if the
softmax is they write it as this form
right here of the exponential of each
entry of a divided by this diagonal
right here
so in the softmax of course you have the
exponential of each entry divided by the
sum of the entries and they write this
simply as two matrices but ultimately
this is a matrix right here and all they
do is they take this P matrix and they
apply the johnson lyndon strauss lemma
by having this projection matrix R and R
is entries from this Gaussian as I said
so this is the special type of
projection that the JL addresses and
then simply says if you pull if you this
here is going to be your P tilde so if
you project or in this manner and obtain
P tilde and then you use P tilde instead
of P then this this is going to be very
close in fact you can reformulate the JL
in two different variants such that it
gives you things like this things like
saying that the distance between this
projected version and this unprojected
version is going to be a constant than a
constant time the norms of the
unprojected version that is equivalent
to saying that the distances are
preserved now you can see right here
nowhere in this theorem is the fact that
the this is self attention and nowhere
in the theorem appears the fact that
this inner matrix a is low rank or even
that this matrix a exists it's you can
do this with any matrix P right the JL
doesn't concern itself with the nature
of this matrix P it says any matrix any
sort of high dimensional data you can
project to low dimensional data and this
holds if you
choose the projection correctly which
they do right here so to claim that this
theorem proves that self attention is
low rank to me is a bit it's a bit of a
statement that is not warranted like the
this here should read something like the
Johnson Lyndon Strauss lemma exists or
something like this it I'm not I'm not
sure like convinced me otherwise but
yeah so they go with this so they say
given the low rank property of the
context mapping matrix P now again I
disagree that this has been shown except
empirically one straightforward idea is
to use singular value decomposition to
approximate P with a low rank matrix P
low as follows so what you could do is
you could simply learn these low rank
matrices and approximate P through it or
you can decompose P as such and then
have these easier inner products in
dimension K but they say however this
approach requires performing an SVD
decomposition in each self attention
matrix which adds additional complexity
therefore we propose another approach
for a low-rank approximation that avoids
this added complexity okay so they now
come up with their model and their model
goes as follows so here on the left you
see a classic attention mechanism with
their projections built in what they're
proposing is they say let's project the
matrix K using one of these random
projections and then this attention
routing if you route if you now multiply
so you multiply K and Q right here K
times Q and then you put it into the
softmax and then you use it to route
this w so they say if we build in this
projection matrix that will project K to
a lower dimension and then we won't have
as expensive
of inner products now the important part
to see here is that if you think of this
lower projection the first thing you
think is that you project this inner
this hidden dimension D right to a lower
dimension and that's not the case here
you actually project the N so in in a
conceptual framework so you can see
right here forget about this this is
this W matrix in a conceptual framework
you see here is this n by D matrix which
are the keys so n is the sequence length
and D is the dimensions and what you
want to do is you want to project that
by this matrix which is K by n so you
want to reduce the sequence length you
can see in this matrix right here why
that might work because n is much larger
than D and that means this matrix can be
at most rank D right so you should not
lose too much you should sort of be able
to preserve the information if you
project this end to a K where the K if
the K is still larger than the D or
approximately in the same order of
magnitude you should be able to preserve
that information if you do in a smart
way so conceptually if we have our five
token sequence like here and the next
layer produces five tokens again what we
first do is we say we know we know that
the information we want is not five
dimensional it's actually two
dimensional because okay let's say these
this inner dimension D is is two as well
so we have two dimensional vectors each
thing exposes two dimensional vectors so
we first project the sequence of length
five to a sequence of length two and we
simply do that in a random manner so we
have random Gaussian matrix that assigns
weights to mix these five into these two
and again because the two JL works for
any sort of data but in my argumentation
if you you know think that this here is
low rank it's of Rank 2
then you shouldn't lose too much
information by projecting it to a
sequence length - and now we do this
attention mechanism so now we expose the
keys and now we expose the queries up
here and now you can see instead of
routing five things with five things you
only have to route five things with two
things and so instead of having oh and
squared
you now have o n K if K K is the number
right here okay so this is the idea you
project the sequence length and it comes
from the fact that the sequence length
is much larger than the dimensionality
and therefore you can sort of preserve
the information if you project in a
smart way they build this in this
fashion right here so the attention
mechanism now before we saw it was
between the queries and the keys right
here
they built now this projection matrix
here that projects the keys into a lower
dimensional sequence and the now such
that this will result in an N by K
attention matrix we saw over here you
don't need to route n by n things you
need to route n by K so this this
routing table in here is now n by K now
the next layer as you can see here it
actually needs to produce
a sequence of length 5 again right so we
always transform sequence of length 5
into sequence of length 5 but now we
have we have this n corresponds to D
sorry corresponds to the next layer and
this K corresponds to the down projected
sequence of the last layer and in order
for that to fit we of course also need
to down project the information that
we're routing so if we don't project the
routing table we also need to down
project the information that we're
routing that's we do this by a similar
matrix F
is also sampled in this way in this
special way and that gives us a K by D
so we have projected the sequence to
size K and if we multiply these two
things again of course we'll get out an
N by d matrix which is the signal for
the next layer okay so an N by D signal
comes in down here it's projected down
to K sequence length it's and it's
routed up again to n sequence length and
you have again an N by d matrix here
cool so that's how they do it and they
build this into the transformer now as I
understand it these projection matrices
again they're not learned they are do
they are built up in this jl conscript
way they are not learned they are fixed
once and then that's that's that at
least that's how I understand it so
there are no more learn herbal
parameters okay so here they have a
demonstration where they up the sequence
length and you can see the batch size
decreases but that's just to sort of
keep the total amount of flops to be
done the same you up the sequence length
and down the batch size as the sequence
length increases the standard
transformers requirement in inference
time goes up and this here as you can
see this is not a linear scale it's a
log scale log too so this goes up with
the sequence length and it should go up
quadratically right and you can also see
that the lint former keeps fairly
constant for the same K now of course as
you increase the K of the lint former
the inference time will go up because
now it's dependent on n times K and not
on n times n ok
so let's look a bit further of how you
have to choose that K
up here in the first theorem we there
was a already hint to it in the first
theorem you had to choose K by five log
N and this is a problem so here you have
log n that means it's not so o of n K is
equal to O of n log n now that's not
linear that's actually that's the same
as the reformer but they want to get to
a linear place and theorem two explains
goes now to a linear shows how you can
make self attention linear okay they
show again
blah-blah-blah-blah now you have to
choose K at the minimum of these two
things and you can see right here that
one of them is independent of n so that
means as n grows of course the minimum
is no longer going to be this here the
minimum is actually going to be the
thing on the left and that is dependent
on just D okay so you have D log D in
here and that makes sense because in the
very beginning we said hey D is actually
much smaller than n and that means the
information that is contained in these
matrices is at most rank D so if we down
project to K we should adjust K to what
D is if we adjust K to about the same
thing as the we're guaranteed to not
lose too much information so now we
choose K according to D instead of
according to N and therefore the
computation is linear in n and n times K
is like n times D to log D so it's
linear in K and linear in D how do we
get there so the first thing they do is
they make the sort of Johnson Lin
Strauss statements again but now instead
of
the general statement they plug in their
actual modified attention mechanism so
here they have a bound on the distance
between if I route my this is the
information to be routed right if I
route my information using the original
softmax and this in here is limbs matrix
a if the original tension mechanism I
won't be too far away as if I were to
route my information using this modified
attention mechanism now the tricky part
here mathematically I believe is that is
exactly the softmax what what I alluded
to right
so this softmax is the tricky part
because if this weren't a softmax so if
the softmax weren't here this would
simply be a projection down and a
projection up and the dilemma would
almost apply as it is written right you
wouldn't have to actually do anything
but the question is if this inside the
softmax is is low-rank
can you make a claim that the entire
softmax then is also a low-rank and it's
not entirely clear because because oh
yes we've done this so you can see right
here that the softmax we haven't
actually done the softmax of a low rank
matrix so we have already seen the low
rank matrix itself and how it
immediately snaps to the to the upper
axis after 128 now if we do the same
thing for the softmax
of that and we probably have to take
away some of these dimensions the first
few let's go with let's go to dimension
100 and look from there okay same thing
okay that's pretty good I did not expect
that
hi there so this is Yannick from the
future I've realized I've been an idiot
and how I constructed these low rank
matrices right here by multiplying em T
by itself of course what's a better way
to do it is to construct two independent
128 dimensional matrices like these two
sub slices of M right here and then
multiplying those together and looking
at the SVD and you as you can see right
here so the softmax of this is now not
of this super low rank anymore it's
still low rank but it's not not very
it's not like hard low rank so if I just
look at the matrix without the softmax
then you can see it has a very peak that
I at the 128 which gives us the
indication it's actually a hundred and
twenty-eight rank which we already knew
but if we now introduce the softmax then
you can see that this vanishes and it's
no longer 128 dimensional and it's only
approximately low rank as you can see
all right back to Yannick in the past
who is wholly surprised that then the
two that but if you multiply MT by
itself that that will give you back the
the exact same thing all right
so did we try this before maybe we did
okay but the mathematical difficulty
still remains and their main thing here
is so they have a first first version
where they pretty much plug it into the
JL again and they they get out this K is
the K needs to be PI log n but they say
this result does not utilize the low
rank property of matrix a and the result
in K has a dependency on sequence like N
and then in the appendix they finally go
through the math to show that now if
they choose a and F like this they can
actually pull
out this and show that the K is where we
already have it the decay is independent
of n like this and I think the main the
main step in this proof is the step B
here where they say uses the fact that
the exponential function is Lipschitz
continuous in a compact region then we
can choose a small enough delta such
that V as you can see here this now
directly relates to this projection
matrix within the exponential function
to the projection matrix out of the
exponential function so you can
basically say that if I project first
and then use the exponential function
that's not too different than if I first
use the exponential function and then
project ok so that's the that's the sort
of of of catch here now they only do
this for the exponential function not
the actual softmax as you can see here
throughout they do it to the exponential
function and also here in their
statements the softmax isn't the
exponential function the softmax is the
exponential function divided by the sum
of the exponential functions but I
believe that this generalizes
straightforwardly alright so for given
choices of Delta and K they have shown
that the lien former in fact can do in a
linear fashion
what a transformer can do in a quadratic
fashion and they are not too far off
okay that's that's their point right
here their results on these benchmarks
oh sorry let's first go to the
perplexities in language modeling so
they show right here that they pretty
much can keep up with the standard
transformer as you can see here so with
the standard transformer they can keep
up here now think that this the the
computation is n times K okay so
something like this Lin former with cake
2:56 will only so instead of n by n it's
n times K it won't save you too much in
that case but it's it's not too
surprising that in fact you have the
same performance because probably the
standard transformer is distributed over
more heads than two so the information
necessarily has a lower dimensionality
ten 256 one thing I want to draw
attention to though here is that you can
see that here it's not really done
learning yet and as you can see the
standard transformer sort of surpasses
all of these models towards the end I
wonder I wonder what happens I'm like I
wouldn't be surprised if they end up
sort of at the same place but I wonder
if these diverged even more right here
after that they also compare with a
higher sequence length and the standard
transformer outperforms the lin former
but of course the point here is that the
lin former is much much much faster and
can keep up now also the scale here of
the perplexity you see these are
percentage points in perplexity but i
can't actually tell if that matters or
not i think i think the original
transformer paper the perplexities
hovered between like three point
something and five point something so
this might actually be sort of
significant differences and I'm not sure
they investigate different methods of
sharing these weights of these arm of
these projections and they seems like
they don't find real differences but I
don't want to go into that because this
video is already really long and then
they look at what happens if they up the
sequence length that they put into the
lin former and you can see that the lin
former can deal with higher sequence
lengths and arrive at the same
perplexities though again i don't know
how many how much diff
that isn't the scale here is larger than
before but yeah so how does this fare on
these benchmarks where you first train a
transformer with pre training with
language modeling and then you use it to
do certain NLP tasks and here you can
see that the lin former is on par in
some of these tasks with the original
transformer but also you can see like a
pattern where you can see pretty wild
results in that you know sometimes the
the lin former here will be better than
this but then also variants of the lin
former will be worse and they'll even be
worse than this and sometimes they'll be
better sometimes this lin former is good
and sometimes the original model is the
best so this sort of points to you can
make the general claim that the lin
former doesn't destroy your gains but
also it's not like a a better model it's
simply a faster model that in some tasks
can keep up with the original model and
the show that of course this is the real
deal here that as you go up in length
the performance gains and also sorry in
this this way the performance gains and
the memory gains that you get by the
informer are dramatic of course the
longer and you go and to the lower
dimension you project the more these
gains are but of course the more
performance you're going to lose
potentially hello again Yannick from the
future i just wanted to draw your
attention on this beautiful broader
impact statement in this paper saying
our work focuses on making transformers
more efficient
everything cool potential positive
inspect impacts of efficient
transformers that's pretty cool
it also has potential impact on training
transformers on images since we can
support very long sequences very cool
furthermore there are positive
environmental benefits very cool i mean
these are all very cool things
they say as such we see no immediate
negative ethical or societal impacts of
our work beyond what applies to the core
building blocks of deep learning do
better now this this honestly I agree
with them right I completely agree with
them that this is sort of a good thing
you might trade off you know some
accuracy you might some make some
approximations but you'll get a much
faster model and this model as any model
can be used you know for things and and
that they now have to pull out of there
out of there but some way in in over
five steps of intermediate layers this
could be used for bad it just seems
ridiculous so good on them for defying
the please also think about negative
impacts right here all right
back to back back to past ionic alright
this was the Lin former paper
I hope this somewhat make sense made
sense to you I had to read it multiple
times for it to make sense to me but
ultimately it's all about the fact that
you have these multiple heads and
therefore your information is probably
lower dimensional and you can abuse that
to just calculate in this lower
dimension all right I'll see you next
time bye-bye